uh thank you we'll check back in with
him throughout the evening time first
leftwing bigotry anti-Semitism running
rampant on University campuses around
the world London Australia what's
happening chanting in a Australia you
know about gas Chambers uh and you know
for Jewish people what is happening on
our college campuses what is happening
among the Democratic party some Harvard
students now are scrambling to finally
resend their support of their vile
letter actually blaming the victim
Israel for the brutal Hamas Terror
attacks not everyone disagrees with them
2024 presidential candidate former
Harvard Professor Cornell West said the
students were largely right but they
lacked Nuance he joins us now with
reaction along with attorney also
Harvard Professor Alan dtz is with us
thank you both for being with us I would
usually you always call me brother Shawn
I call you brother Cornell I'm not I'm
not that happy with you you tonight I
understand we could talk about why we
because we have 31 groups from Harvard
Harvard's supposed to be I always
thought the the the top of the top to
get into Harvard what a what an
accomplishment what an achievement what
what accademic Excellence you must show
a A Cut Above everyone else and 31
student groups blaming Israel blaming
the victim and your answer to this is
they are largely right Hamas that
murdered children Hamas that murdered
innocent what I said though brother rest
what I said they are largely right but
lacking Nuance no that I didn't say lack
Nuance that's the title of the piece
okay actual words were I just be very
honest I got it here in front of me
words too the words were that Israel's
policies of war crimes and Collective
punishment against
Palestinians Israel and the United
States
must take responsibility for killing
innocent people anybody who kills
innocent people are engaging in barbaric
act said no matter who they are what
color what nation and so forth Israel
and the united states are primar the
United States has supported and enable
you explain to this audience I want you
to explain how how is Israel and the
United States responsible for beheading
40 children
how I'm talking about the context 5
45 Palestinian children died in August
2004 not one American said a word I
believe a Palestinian baby has the same
value as an Israeli baby so when you
have that kind of vicious hatred and
revenge you get response of hatred and
revenge they are all wrong they're all
war crimes they're all to be condemned
but you cannot simply look at this
particular moment without the larger
backdrop of a ugly occupation and the
Ugly attacks chronically against
Palestinian not your words largely right
Israel and the United States are
primarily responsible for this attack
Professor dtz well I complained when
Palestinian children were killed but I
explained why they were killed here is
one of the leaders of Hamas for the
Palestinian people death has become an
industry the elderly excel at this and
so do the children this is why we have
formed human shield s of the women and
the children Hamas is the ones
responsible for the killing of
Palestinian children also the Hamas has
a term it's called the CNN strategy and
the CNN strategy is induce Israel into
killing Palestinian children by using
them as human Shields then parade the
bodies out on CNN and you'll see what
happens people like Cornell West will
engage in crocodile tears blame it on
Israel when the entire blame is on the
Palestinians Hamas for using their
children their children as human Shields
and then using their children as Shield
to
per don't accuse
me I have the same outrage when
Palestinian babies are killed when
Jewish babies isra I want you to have
the same indignation when Palestinians
are killed not when they're not when
they're killed by Palestinians when that
you can't make a moral comparison when
Nazi kids were killed in the bombings of
Dresden I didn't have the same
comparison when Jewish kids were put in
gas Chambers in crematoriums you're a
professor of theology don't you
understand the moral difference between
deliberately murdering a kid and having
collateral damage because they are human
Shields you're running for president of
the United States what would you do wait
wait wait let me tell you let me ask the
question let me ask the question what
would you do if they were firing of
terrorists were firing at American
children in America and the terrorists
were hiding behind Palestinian children
would you allow the killing of Americans
to continue or would you go and get the
terrorists even if it meant possibly
collateral damage on Palestinians what
would you do I'll tell you exactly what
I would do first truth and morality tend
to be too casual IES in any context of
War I would want to tell the American
people the truth I would tell them what
the context is how we found ourselves in
this situation I would not jump for a
military Invasion and a genocidal attack
on a a genocidal attack on
Gaza where are they supposed to go where
they supposed to go this is like Warsaw
1943 where do they go where do they go
let me tell you where they go to they go
to the UN is keeping to they go to no no
no the UN has places in Gaza they go to
theck un people have been killed in the
last few days they go to Egypt they GOP
had to out let make another thing clear
Gaza City is very dense but Gaza itself
the Gaza Strip there's lots of room the
Israelis have said get out of Gaza City
go to Rafa go to uh conun go to other
places and you know what Hamas water no
F no electricity saying Hamas is saying
don't go I'm not here to defend Hamas
I'm not defending Hamas you ever lie on
me like that brother I'm defending the
suffering and of
Palestinians Hamas committing War crime
anybody who commits war crimes are
barbaric I'm saying that explicitly but
I want you to say if the Israeli Defense
Forces are killing children are they
barbaric too are they ever no no if they
target if they target children have they
ever targeted children never ever never
in the history have they ever targeted a
child you got to get off the crack man
please no no they never think kill one
innocent person not purposely 1948 not
not are they that pure are they that you
have to be very pure not to kill a child
not to kill a child let me kill
550 they're being used as human Shields
let me show something we show on this
program last night I'm about to show
this audience these are cartoons that
are air in Gaza for young children that
are taught to hate the Jewish people you
Ju Just watch this for a second and I'll
have you both comment watch
that
[Music]
then
Professor West if you brainwash and
indoctrinate young
children that you're teaching them to
hate from that young age not good no
here's the problem any kind of of hatred
is moral and wrong here's the problem I
have with brother and others if there's
any hatred of anybody palan you condemn
black lives matter Chicago for
justifying the Hamas Murder by using
these little airplane things and coming
down on the U music EV I I would
certainly condemn it you condemn black
lives matter I would condemn anybody
it's not a matter of this is morality
and spirituality brother okay so you
condemn black lives matter part part of
our challenge though and this is this is
important just as as a leader you see he
asked me what I would do I would say
we've got the in occup
we got to make sure that Palestinians
have the same dignity the same rights as
Israel that's at the CER you know I
support that you know I support the two
State Sol but Hamas doesn't support the
two State solution Hamas West I want to
ask this question would Gaza be facing
Annihilation if Hamas did not attack and
kill all these innocent Israelis of
course not Gaza has been facing not
answering chronic facing
anihilation since 2 would they
be since 2006 and 7 and Gaza was taken
over by Hamas I'm not pro Hamas I'm Pro
democracy but I'm concerned about the
suffering of palestin Isel didn't fire a
single rocket until Hamas fired 5,000
Rockets controls the land the air only
after the food going in the trade coming
in and so but it was already under
occupation since 1966 no no no the
occupation ended 2005 learn your history
Shon left every American every Israeli
settler every Israeli soldier left in
2006 it was like Singapore it could have
been the nicest place in the
Mediterranean then Hamas overthrew them
New York would been occupation if
another country own its air its space it
food going between
containment after let let me end with
this here's a sad fact this debate could
not be held on Harvard's campus today
correct that's right I would not be
allowed off go up to Har I am offering
to go up to Harvard and do and I will
moderate it we've debated before and
many I think Harvard will let Professor
dtz or Professor brother Hannity on the
campus well you could go with me well
I'll go and have a publicate and and
then I'll tell you that but the truth is
going to be difficult would you all like
to see that in this audience
absolutely and we'll bring our audience
with hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere
else